Here's how my $250 million plus
portfolio actually makes money. Welcome
to ACQ. I'm Alex, co-founder of the
company, and the point of this video is
to help show you how acquisition.com and
ACQ actually make money. And so, what I
want to walk you through is how we turn
raw attention, so eyeballs, into money.
And then, what we do with that money to
kind of spin the entire flywheel. And we
do all of this in the service of the
larger mission, which is to make real
business education accessible for
everyone. And the reason we made that
the mission is because when Leila and I
had sold our first company, we're like,
"You know what? What's something that
gets us out of bed every day? What's
something that we're really motivated
by?" And we are products of the personal
development, um, alternative education,
if you will, world. And it's the thing
that lights us up the most. And there
are very few people who have the
credibility to teach business. There's
some people do it. Uh, not all people
who have a lot of credibility who do it.
And the people have the most credibility
don't do it because they're doing other
stuff. And so, we thought that that'd be
a really good void to attack. So, let's
walk through how we actually make money.
So,
at the onset,
we have eyeballs. So, there's this big
world of people out here, right? And so,
these eyeballs for us, the ones that we
are really targeting, are business
owners and people who are 1° from that,
which would be business interested,
wantrepreneurs, seekers, people who want
to turn whatever they do into some sort
of business. Now, the vast majority of
people who are what I would consider the
wantrepreneurs, um, we help them
directly, but mostly for free. Um, and
then, the business owners who ascend up
are the ones that we end up eventually
monetizing and create further
relationships with. And so, you can kind
of think of this kind of like an onion,
and there's going to be a handful of
arrows that work around, but I'll do my
very best to describe this to you. So,
in order to kind of get people into our
world, uh, the first thing we do is have
good markers.
So, we have There we go. That's nicer.
All right. So, this is where we put our
media. So, this is kind of the first big
input that we have as a business. This
is where our content goes. This is
courses that we have on our site. Um,
content,
podcasts, etc. YouTube videos, all of
this stuff goes in here. This is what we
create every day. We put money, we put
effort, and we put team into this. All
right. This thing gets some of this
attention. And so, then we move to the
next part of this process. So, we have
to get this raw attention to then give
us some sort of contact information so
that we can create some sort of
conversion event. Now, depending on
where, uh, these people are, um, some
people convert because they want to join
our email list for the Mosey Minute,
which is in some ways a product in of
itself, which then gets people on that
list so we can further advertise to
them.
The next, um, thing that some people do
is that they'll, um,
go to School, which is one of our
portfolio companies, uh, that we have,
so people can start communities online.
It's the only big brand, um,
association that we've made publicly.
And that company, you know, continues to
grow and grow and grow. And the rest of
kind of the conversion mechanism then
goes to books. So, this is people who
buy books on our site or buy books on
Amazon.
Um, and through these things, we get
these kind of like minor conversions.
This is, you know, a free trial into a
$9 thing. This is a $30 book. This is a
free email list. So, once we have these
conversions that come in,
um, at this point, we can funnel them to
the different components of the business
that have higher, um,
value-added services that we can offer
them. Now, as of today, we really only
have one, which is AP, or the advisory
practice.
These are the workshops that we actually
hold in Vegas at our headquarters with
our associates, our analysts, our
directors who help hands-on with
business owners. And so, we have three
levels within the advisory practice. We
have L1, L2, and L3. And some of these
things may be subject to change, but as
they currently exist right now, this is
about $5,000. This is $35,000. And this
is $135,000.
And so, people come into L1. A certain
percentage of those people then say,
"Hey, I want more help." So, they go to
L2. And some of those people say, "Hey,
I want even more help, specifically from
Alex or more detailed help." And they go
to L3. Very simple names here. Now,
underneath of this,
um, this then generates, obviously,
revenue. And this is where it gets a
little bit more interesting. And I'm
going to fill this extra space in in a
moment. But,
as the revenue comes out the other side
here, right, and we have revenue that
comes in from our media as well, right,
and books also create revenue, and
School also gives us revenue. But, all
of these things then shuttle to money on
this side, right? All of these are in
some ways revenue-producing.
Once we have this revenue, we then
redeploy this revenue into various
buckets. So, one of them is ACQRE, so
that's our real estate arm. This is
where we buy real estate properties,
typically multi-family. We have a good
partnership through Arc.
Um, and we've raised funds to do these
properties in these deals. And we can
also solicit back to the front of our
audience and say, "Hey, would you like
to do deals alongside us?" But, this is
one of the prior methods that we
reinvest cash,
um,
the cash that we have. And part of this
is because it's also tax efficient for
us as a business. Um,
and so, that's one of the places that we
put the money.
The next place is that we that we put
the money. And this is, obviously,
outside of more people, more
infrastructure, more tech, the
reinvestments that we put inside of the
business. The excess cash,
um, goes into ACQ
Ventures.
So, this is our venture portfolio. This
is where we make, um, either one of two
scenarios. We either make very, very
small bets on kind of unicorn-style tech
companies. So, we're talking, you know,
1 2 3 5% bets,
um, in in smaller companies that we
think have high growth potential. Or,
we're actually seeding a company at the
onset that we think is a good idea that
we can then sell through this
distribution base. Now, the reason that
this is important for anybody who's
joining the ACQ team is that the
ultimate career path that I see for
anybody who does a really good job,
especially like in the advisory
practice, is that you get so many
repetitions of learning how businesses
work, our process of creating value in
businesses, that who do we think are the
best people to start some of these other
ventures that we would love to kind of
sponsor on the way in? Well, the people
who actually have implemented our
process across 100 different businesses,
right? And so, this is where
we will have, um,
you could you could kind of consider
this as a separate arms here kind of
coming this way. But, this is where
insurance, uh, you know, lending,
um, you know, some sort of sales AI.
There's tons of different opportunities
that are here that businesses that are
in our ecosystem would love to
participate in. And we would love to
fund those, uh, opportunities for people
who are on our team.
So, we have our real estate arm. We have
the venture arm. Um, and then, beyond
that, this is more or less the landscape
of what acquisition.com looks like. So,
what's all this blank space here? So,
the blank space here is these pieces
as they will exist in the future, right?
This is where we will probably have the
ACQ Network, right? So, a business owner
association, which is a more scalable
offering that costs less than this
in-person,
um, experience or consulting work that
we do. And people would just simply get
value from the network of many other
business owners. Included in this would
be our AI, um, kind of business
consultant that has been trained on all
of this in-person experience here. Uh,
they have, obviously, the community of
other people. Uh, they'll have industry
calls based on the best practices that
we find from the AI that we're seeing
people who are like in home services or
health care or brick and mortar or
professional services. And so, this is a
a membership that'll probably be, and
this is this is probably looking at
2026, somewhere in the neighborhood of,
you know, $5,000 to $10,000 per year,
um,
as a membership. So, this is not
intended to be some super, super
expensive thing. It's intended to have
enough of a barrier of entry that it
should be only for business owners.
Um, but the aggregate value of that
distribution base, one, obviously,
provides cash flow for us, which then
feeds this entire machine. But, also,
this base gives us a stronger
negotiating position for vendors. So, if
we say, "Hey, you know, all these guys
want to have an agency. We don't want to
do agency work, but we'd love to find a
handful of agencies that we could
pre-negotiate a great deal for them.
Hey, we have, uh, you know, a credit
card provider that has specific benefits
to the size businesses that we look at.
Um, can we negotiate on behalf of
thousands of businesses at once we can
get better rates or better deals?" All
the way across the board. And so, this
then creates a huge value out of network
where the savings accrued, uh, and the
value added is so far in excess of this
that no one would ever want to leave.
And that's kind of the that's kind of
the thought process behind this. And so,
this in the future will actually, in my
opinion, sit as the base mechanism. And
then, a certain percentage of these
people will go up, and they will send,
um, into the various other things. So,
it could be advisory practice. They
might ascend into sales AI. They might
ascend into lending. They might ascend
into insurance. They might decide to do
a real estate deal with us. We might
decide to invest in their business,
uh, from the venture, uh, component.
And then, the last piece here is that we
do have our private equity side, right?
And so, some of these businesses that
come in on the advisory practice or the
ACQ Network, we eventually say, "Hey,
instead of taking, you know, 1 to 5%
chunks, we may take a 30 to, you know,
50 1 or even 100 100% stake, uh, in this
business and allow it to run
independently. Maybe take some of our
talent and put it inside of it." It's a
functionally, this is the ACQ universe.
And so, if we're to fast forward and
say, "Okay, well, like, what's the
vision? What does this look like when
it's right?" So, that's kind of the flow
of how the money would work. But, if you
have if you want to have a different
visual of how this looks like, we have
this big media arm at the top. This is
the big brand, right? And then, from
that brand, we're essentially able to
monetize it in many, many, many
different ways. And so, if you were to
think of this like Disney, so Disney is
a big brand, and they have their Star
Wars universe. They have their Marvel
universe. They have their their theme
parks. They have Disney Plus. And so,
for us, the Disney Plus version of this
is essentially the ACQ Network. It's a
B2B version of something that would have
some level of media and education, but
also a lot of ancillary benefits. But,
it's super scalable. It's meant to be
something that everyone can participate
in. Outside of the obviously just the
content that the whole world can
participate in. Beyond that, they have
their parks, right? And for us, the
parks translates in a B2B setting as the
advisory practice. This is where they
come in person, they get a great
experience with us, they get hands-on
help from our team, the people that
they've looked up to, the people that
made a lot of the case studies that come
out in our content. They actually get to
meet them. So, this is meeting Mickey,
Mickey meeting Minnie, meeting Goofy,
and all those people, but in a B2B
context.
Now,
um the remainder of these pieces are the
other the other spokes. So, for the Star
Wars, that's like what's the Star Wars
universe here? So, for us, that would be
like school. That's like a franchise
that we're invested in for a specific
type of avatar. There's a lot of people
who have knowledge and they would like
to monetize that in some sort of
community, and we own the platform,
right? Or we're co-founders of the
platform. And so, this is a mechanism
for us to take some percentage of the
audience that isn't maybe ready for the
advisory practice or ACQ Network and put
them in here. Now, some of these people
are totally qualified for these other
things cuz this can scale, but it's such
a low barrier entry at like a $9 a month
price point that it completely works,
right? Now,
the future arms here are going to be the
other elements in the future. Like I
said, the insurance,
you know, sales AI,
and plenty of other opportunities that
are going to come up. Now, where did
where does the, you know, private equity
and the the the real estate arm fit in
here? Well, these are just other spokes
that are still on this larger
machine.
And the difference is that our, I'll
call it legacy portfolio, were just
companies that we thought we could
provide value to.
Future-looking, we're trying to only do
deals, especially in the private equity
side, to companies that we think can
directly benefit the distribution base
of businesses that we have, rather than
just be businesses that we're very
comfortable growing, instead be
businesses that we think can handle the
scale
of what we bring. And so, this is where
the types of bets we're doing at ACQ
Ventures, which will then stand up some
of these other entities.
And
the ACQ already, which we can obviously
raise from the audience. But
functionally, this is what we're doing.
We're trying to build this universe
where once a business owner comes in,
they don't want to leave because we have
provided, you know, so much value on the
media side, so much value in the
network, or, you know, when they came
out in person to to meet us and meet the
team in the consulting work that we did,
they were like, "You know what? I want
to I trust them, and I would like to
invest my money with them. I would like
to
buy insurance there. I would like to use
their platform for the community that I
have for my drumming business, or for
my,
you know, real estate business. I put
all my home buyers into a school
community so I can stay in touch with
them, right? So, this is what we are
building. And
functionally, the flow of money is
straightforward. We put money and effort
here, we then capture capture
information here, we convert through
different conversion mechanisms. So, we
had a launch, and this is where we had a
webinar
that went to the book
packages,
which for us was
6K.
>> [gasps]
>> Here, the ACQ Network, this might be a
checkout, it might be a phone, it might
be both. Here, we do almost all these
conversions over the phone. So, our
phone team then sells people into these
various levels.
But functionally, that is how the money
works and how we make money at
acquisition.com. We make money from our
content, we make money from people
buying books, we make money from people
buying school, and obviously there's
equity value in that company as well,
but we also get distributions from
school as well.
We make money from all the people who
come to our parks, our themes. In the
future, we'll make money from the people
who join the network. And
we'll make money from all the other
ancillary services that they choose to
buy. And should they choose to invest
with us, we would make money there, too.
But all of this is predicated on the one
single promise that has to be true
before any of this works, which is that
we have to make real business education
accessible for everyone. And we have to
make our free stuff better than everyone
else's paid stuff. And we have to
maintain absolute premium brand
credibility, that we are who we say we
are, that we've done what we've said
we've done, so that that reinforces the
position that we have in the
marketplace. And functionally, this is a
position that very few people can occupy
because the only people that I think
have more credibility than us, most of
them don't want to do this part. They're
just running their businesses. And I
think this is the unique the unique
wedge in the marketplace that exists
that we are capitalizing on.
And at the end of the day, what we're
doing is we're helping the people that
we care the most about, which is the
backbone of the economy,
the small business owner. And from a
what who is the avatar for this?
For us right now,
in terms of our monetization, it's
usually about $500,000 to $50 million in
revenue is kind of our sweet spot of the
business owners that are coming in
through this network. Now, for everybody
who's less than $500,000 per year,
it doesn't mean that there's zero quote
monetization of those those those people
or those eyeballs. It's just different.
It's very distributed. And so, we're
going to get some ad revenue that comes
from the platforms. We're we're we're
monetizing through a lower ticket, you
know, platform here. Books are, you
know, between, you know, the books are
free, but if people want a hard copies,
they can buy them, or if they want to
buy them on Audible, they can get them.
We can we make a couple bucks on that
stuff.
But for these people, the goal is not to
monetize in this way. The goal is that
these people use these these tools to
create businesses that then ascend them
into this category, which then opens up
this entire universe of potential
products and services that we can we can
help them continue to scale their
business. And then ultimately, maybe we
buy the company, maybe we invest as a
venture company, maybe they just make
enough money to exit and they want to
put some of their money with us in the
the real estate arm,
or they just want to buy other services
from us. And so, functionally, this is
what we're building,
and we're super excited to have you on.
And hopefully that helps you understand
a little bit better of how ACQ makes
money. This is actually an internal
recruiting video that we share to new
recruits, and I thought it would be cool
for one, you guys to see everyone I
think should have a video sales letter
that sells your company as the product
to new potential candidates. And then
second, if you are a true A-player,
especially AR tech forward in any kind
of function of the department or roles
within a business, we'd love to talk to
you.
Hopefully my team will put the little
link here. Apply if you're a star, and
we are always hiring for A-talent.
Doesn't matter the role, we're always
hiring.